five four we'll talk about it yeah yes
and we're live hello hey Joe welcome
thank you
it's great to be here thanks for having
me my pleasure Sam Harris sends his
regards
yeah Sam's a beautiful man he is I love
that guy
and he's one of the reasons why you're
here so universal basic income this is
what this is all about yes
yeah that's what my campaign for
president is all about that's a an
interesting like focus of a campaign and
and very unusual and I mean four years
ago you'd never even thought that that
would have a chance at all but this is a
subject that has been gaining momentum
and it made it I made a big shift
because I had my friend Eddie Wong on
once and he was the first person to
bring it up and my initial knee-jerk
reaction was get the [ __ ] out here like
universal basic income just gonna give
people money they're just gonna be lazy
nothing's ever gonna get done that's a
terrible idea
and then I started paying attention to
the rise of AI and automation and how
many jobs are gonna get taken away and
then once you see the actual numbers
it's pretty staggering
yeah and that's how I got there Joe like
I spent the last seven years running an
organization that I'd started called
venture for America and we helped create
about 3,000 jobs in Detroit Cleveland
st. Louis Birmingham New Orleans other
cities around the country and I saw that
we're pouring water into a bathtub that
has a giant hole ripped in the bottom
and that for every 5 10 50 jobs that my
entrepreneurs are gonna create we're
gonna lose 5 10 50,000 jobs it's not
something that people intuitively
suspect could be a real issue either
it's it's one of the ones where you kind
of have to let go
shake people like hey look at this this
is coming there's a cliff we're going
towards this cliff
it's it's darker still and that so when
I was digging into the numbers I found
that it's not this cliff that we're
heading towards it's actually more of a
curve that we're on what I've been
telling people is that we're in the
third inning now where one of the main
reasons why Donald Trump won in 2016 is
that we automated away four million
manufacturing jobs that were based in
Michigan Pennsylvania Ohio
Wisconsin Missouri Iowa all the swing
states he needed to win in the center of
the country and a lot of that was just
manufacturing work and if you go to a
factory you'll see it says giant robot
arms as far as the eye can see so it's
not just that you have artificial
intelligence on the horizon it's that
we've been eating away at the most
common jobs in the US economy for almost
20 years now and it's just now hitting a
point where it's pushing more and more
unskilled men in particular out of the
workforce now are there other
alternatives that you've considered
other than just universal basic income
like educating people about this being a
real issue and perhaps pushing them or
directing them towards other occupations
yeah so that that's the recipe that most
people are attracted to so I just want
to unpack the numbers a little bit more
so people have a sense of it I was just
with a bunch of truck drivers in Iowa
last week and there's a guy Dennis
bagasse key that gave me a ride from
Altoona to Grinnell and Iowa where I've
been campaigning and the truth of it Joe
is that there are three and a half
million truck drivers in this country
right now it's the most common job in 29
states and the average trucker is a 49
year old guy with a high school
education
maybe ex-military like Dennis was and
they're making like fifty thousand
dollars a year so then if you say hey
I'm gonna retrain half a million truck
drivers for what exactly is like issue
number one right and then these guys
didn't love school 30 years ago it's not
like driving a truck has made them
really excited about the idea yeah and
then the new job you're training them
for I looked into the data as to how
good we were at retraining let's say
displaced manufacturing workers in the
Midwest when we started decimating their
jobs and we're terrible at like
according to independent studies
government-funded retraining programs
had a success rate of between zero and
15% in real life like this is what
actually happened to the workers of
Michigan and Indiana and Ohio and so if
you say we're gonna retrain these people
then you also have to come up with a way
for us to become amazing at something
that right now we're really really bad
at and if you were an employer which you
are
would you rather employ a 50 year old
former truck driver with health problems
who got some certificate
or would you rather hire a 25 year old
kid who went to Community College is
probably cheaper has lower expectations
and his skills are natively going to be
a little fresher I mean if you were an
employer you'd probably choose number
two I agree
but I'm I mean I'm trying to look at
this through rose-colored glasses I
guess welcome to thank you if there's a
way that these people can adapt you know
I mean some will for sure you can
retrain and rescale some people but if
you look at even the conversations we're
having around this where people
legitimately talk about retraining coal
miners to be software engineers stuff
that on the face of it makes no sense
but the the reason why we're stretching
for that is because we're looking for
some kind of retraining oriented
solution when the numbers show that
that's just not going to be the recipe
there for actual success and this is
where this whole learned to code
controversies coming out online where
people are actually getting banned for
writing learn to code it's a really a
hot subject on Twitter and it's very
confusing too and I haven't really
gotten an explanation for why that's
such an offensive thing to say but
people are getting banned or even joking
around saying learn to code and it's
very weird but the idea behind it is
that it's kind of preposterous to ask
someone who doesn't have an education to
do something that's as difficult as code
computer language yeah and unfortunately
we're gonna get to a point where AI can
do some basic coding at a certain level
so if you think about the impulse to say
learn to code what it's really saying is
you need to do something that the market
values mmm-hmm it's like hey being a
truck driver the markets not going to
value that much when the truck start
driving themselves in the next five to
ten years so what does the market value
and then people are like well coding and
stem and and engineering skills and so
there's a drive to try and push people
in those directions but if you look at
the numbers about 8% of American jobs
right now are in STEM fields like in
technology engineering math etc so you
talking about 92 percent of the
population that is not in those fields
and it's unrealistic to expect that 92%
to somehow shift into the eight percent
right in there
even be places for them there yeah
that's true too even if they perfectly
seamlessly transition there's too many
people for those jobs yeah so I've been
driven to universal basic income in part
because I've been looking at the numbers
the five most common jobs in the United
States right now are administrative and
clerical work retail and sales food
service and food prep truck driving and
transportation and manufacturing those
five jobs comprise about half of all
American jobs
only 32 percent of Americans graduate
from college so the average American is
a high school grad
doing one of these five jobs and if you
look at it technology is already doing a
number on each of these jobs like the
first administrative and clerical
includes call center workers and AI is
in the process of taking over that job
retail and sales 30% of malls are
closing in the next four years so that
the danger here is to think of it as
artificial intelligence is coming it's
actually already eating up the most
common jobs in our economy and it's
driving Americans into distress in
various ways in the numbers now when
you're talking about universal basic
income - there's two questions to come
up how much money and where is it coming
from yeah so first I want to say that if
you look at the heritage of universal
basic income it's a deeply American idea
where Thomas Paine was forward at the
founding of the country and then Martin
Luther King was for it Milton Friedman
the Godfather of conservative economists
was for it and one state has had it in
effect for 37 years where everyone in
that state gets between one and two
thousand dollars a year no questions
asked this is Alaska yeah it's Alaska
and they funded with oil money and what
I'm going around telling people is that
technology is the oil of the 21st
century so I know you spoke to another
guest about hey how do you get let's say
approximately three trillion dollars a
year to fund universal basic income and
the great thing is that it's well the
first thing is it's not actually three
trillion and the reason why it's not
three trillion is that if you look at
what we're currently doing we have we're
spending about 1.5 trillion right now
126 welfare programs and Social Security
and so if you show up to someone's door
and say hey here's a dividend of $1,000
a month but if you're already getting
more than a thousand dollars and stuff
we're not just gonna stack it on top you
know we're gonna just gonna say you're
guaranteed a thousand and if you're
already getting more than this doesn't
touch you you can keep your current
stuff if you're getting 700 and and
whatnot then you can just get 300 on top
so the three trillion actually shrinks a
lot very fast because of the fact that
about half of Americans are already
getting various income support from the
government so the real price tag is
closer to about 1.8 trillion if you say
everyone who's 18 and up now for context
the entire US economy is now 20 trillion
up five trillion in the last 12 years
and the federal budgets four trillion so
you're looking at 1.8 trillion it's a
lot of money but it's actually
manageable and one of the things that I
haven't heard discussed here with you is
that when you put money into people's
hands the money doesn't disappear like
if I gave you a thousand bucks a month
it probably would not make a big
difference in the economy because
they're just going to your account
somewhere and you know nothing would
happen but we all know that right now
most Americans are living paycheck to
paycheck 57 percent of Americans can't
afford an unexpected $500 bill so you
put $1,000 a month into their hands it's
gonna go right back in the economy
they're gonna spend it on food child
care car repairs they've been putting
off the occasional night out and then
all of those businesses end up hiring
more people and then we end up getting
some of the money back as tax revenues
so of the 1.8 trillion you were gonna
get back let's call it 400 billion in
new tax receipts because everyone's
gonna be spending more money we're gonna
save one to two hundred billion on
things like incarceration and
homelessness services and emergency room
health care I was in New Hampshire last
month and a prison guard said to me
there's a prison guard
he said we should pay people to stay out
of jail because we waste so much money
when they're in jail like he sees all
the waste in the system so if you
imagine a society where everyone's
getting a thousand bucks a month that's
like a it's a great incentive to try and
stay out of jail because you know you
stop getting hit if you wind up in jail
and it reduces recidivism because when
you
mataji at least you have you know a
thousand bucks a month waiting for you
and then you're less inclined to to
commit a crime and head back in how much
crime do you think you'd actually
prevent though by giving people a
thousand dollars a month
I mean think most of the people that are
doing crime whether it's thief thievery
or assault they're not thinking this out
you know this is this is just either a
way of life for them either
you know they're they've got real mental
issues or a pattern of behavior that
they can't break I really don't think
that $1,000 a month is gonna fix any of
that well it's not gonna fix all of it
for sure
and we will still have jails it's not
like you know Silver Bullet you know but
at the margins would it keep like that
person who's falling through the cracks
and feels like they have no place in
society and maybe they you know it's
like the people around them are also
like hey you know you don't have any
value and though you get a thousand
bucks a month maybe like it keeps them
off at the margins and everything we're
talking about is at the margins I mean
everything's like this statistical curve
and you're taking the people who are
let's call it like the last 10 to 20
percent but if you reduce our
incarcerated population by 10 to 20
percent I mean that's billions and
billions of dollars so you you're saving
money on a bunch of things we spend like
about a trillion dollars on right now
like health care incarceration
homelessness services and then the the
magic is that if you have a thousand
bucks a month and you're a parent so you
feel this that studies have shown that
your kids are healthier better nourished
more likely to graduate from high school
and get further education mental health
improves relationships improve domestic
violence Goes Down hospital visits go
down and your worker productivity goes
up I mean you're an entrepreneur and CEO
so you know when you run a company you
say I'm gonna invest in my people I'm
gonna like treat them well and try and
train them and give them resources
because you know that'll increase your
productivity as an organization in the
public sector we have the opposite
approach where like if I can just avoid
spending money on you said you know I'm
gonna somehow save money when we end up
spending that money in very very dark
costly counter
two ways in the backend because they
wind up you know in our institutions and
our institutions just spend a truckload
of money so if you look at the cost
savings and the value gains and the
economic growth that actually gets you
back about a trillion dollars or the 1.8
this is like the trickle up economy
because none of the money disappears it
goes right back into the economy and the
way you get the last eight hundred
billion or so is related to what we
think is happening with AI and all these
advanced technologies because if you
look at who's gonna win with AI and
self-driving cars and trucks the savings
from robot trucks are estimated to be a
hundred sixty eight billion dollars a
year just from that one thing so the
problem is that the American public is
going to see very little of that money
because the winners are gonna be the
trillion dollar tech companies that are
great it is not paying a lot of taxes
they'll move it through Ireland Amazon
will say didn't make any money this
quarter no reason to pay taxes and so
what we need to do is we need to put in
a new tax that actually gets the
American public a slice of every robot
truck mile Amazon transaction facebook
ad and every other industrialized
country already has this tax it's called
a value-added tax and because our
economy is so vast at 20 trillion a
value-added tax that even half the
European level generates about 800
billion in new revenue and that gets you
all the way there so this is much more
achievable and affordable than most
people think when they start unpacking
how the numbers work out so essentially
it'll be the biggest corporations the
the companies that gain or that have the
largest revenue they're gonna be paying
most of this yeah but they're gonna get
some of that money back obviously
because how the things I say to the CEOs
it's like if everyone in Missouri is
getting a thousand bucks you know
Amazon's gonna see some of that because
they're just gonna buy more stuff right
that's true for all of the big companies
what I say to CEOs and I've spoken to
groups of dozens of CEOs what's really
bad for your business is when people
don't have money to spend what's good
your businesses when they do so they're
gonna give up some money at the top and
my thing just gonna end up getting it
back when their consumers end up
spending a bit more it has just been
actually fleshed out like the the real
numbers or the projections of how
we're gonna get back yeah yeah like the
so the Roosevelt Institute studied this
plan of everyone getting a thousand
bucks a month and projected it would
create two million new jobs and grow the
economy by eight to ten percent and then
you can model out what that means to
each business because in that climate
they're gonna see a similar uptick in
revenues did they factor in all the jobs
that are going to be lost so one of the
things that's a misconception about
universal basic income is that it
somehow will like facilitate job loss
well for job losses though is the reason
for universal basic income in the first
place right yeah yeah which way in the
midst of right now like right now is
we're sitting here together the labor
force participation rate in the United
States is sixty-three percent which is
the same levels as El Salvador in the
Dominican Republic
that's right now like 94 million or so
Americans have left the workforce over
the last number of years now a lot of
that's natural demographics a lot of
that's people in school but about five
million of it is unskilled men who have
gotten pushed out of the workforce so
till again this is not like you know
we're gonna solve a problem that's
coming down the pike like we're actually
in the middle of this problem so if you
put a thousand bucks a month into
people's hands it actually grows the
economy and creates jobs because of more
economic activity now when you say a
problem that's coming down the pike what
what are the projections in terms of
life a timeline yes so there are a lot
of the projections are actually pretty
consistent with each other which means
they're probably right so the so Bane
says you're looking at between 20 and 30
percent of jobs subject to automation by
2030 which is pretty soon it's like 11
years from now McKenzie says about 25
percent the Obama White House literally
like their last day in office they
issued a report saying hey guys we're
gonna automate away all the jobs and
then like you know turn the lights off
they said eighty-three percent of jobs
that make less than twenty dollars an
hour will be subject to automation by
2030 MIT is saying the same thing and so
we have 11 years to try and accelerate
meaningful solutions and this 11 years
it's not like it all happens on
thirty it's gonna happen between now and
then progressively according to all of
the major institutions that have looked
at this now when you take a guy who's
working as a truck driver and he's
making $50,000 a year and you tell him
that automation is gonna take away his
job but good news we're gonna give you
twelve thousand dollars a year that's a
substantial loss in income and yeah it
leaves them in yeah it also leaves them
with this feeling of uselessness or
hopelessness that they're not
contributing you know I think one of the
things that people enjoy is earning
their own way you know they people don't
it sounds counterintuitive people don't
like free money they like a feeling of
satisfaction of a job well done that
they've created something they've done
something yeah you're a hundred percent
right it's one reason why we call this
the freedom dividend we say look it's
not money for nothing you're an owner
and chair holder of the richest country
in the history of the world just like
when I buy Verizon or Microsoft they
send me a dividend like I don't complain
about that like you're now a shareholder
in this great nation and you get a
dividend but when I was with Dennis the
trucker who owns his own trucking
company in Iowa the the role that jobs
playing in truckers lives is vital and
again I'm a very data-driven guy where
men deal with joblessness very very
poorly yeah by the numbers we spend
between forty and seventy five percent
of our time on the computer playing
video games or doing other things our
substance abuse goes up our volunteering
and the community goes down even though
we have more time hmm and we generally
spiral into antisocial and
self-destructive behaviors now this is
not something that's experienced by
women in the same levels like women and
joblessness women actually a more
adaptable they're more likely to go back
to school and volunteer they don't spend
all their time on the computers the way
that we do so there's a real problem and
the purpose of universal basic income is
not meant to be a job replacement for
those truckers because right now those
truckers and when I talked to the truck
driver
so I've been campaigning for president
now for a number of months so I spent a
lot of time in Iowa which is a really
huge trucking hub and you go to them and
say hey guys you worried about robot
trucks taking your jobs they're like
there's no way a robot could take my job
like that that's you know that's like
totally matter-of-fact
there like that like this is not
something that they worry about their
attitude has transitioned from that
somewhat - we should make robot trucks
illegal or we should make it so that a
robot truck cannot displace me so that's
been a big shift because a year ago they
were like it's impossible the idea that
a American would say we should make a
robot job illegal like it's we should
have some laws that keep you from being
free to use robots for your business
instead of person like you should be
forced to highly mandatory unionization
or something that sounds pretty
ridiculous well that's where a lot of
them are Joe so only 13% of truckers are
unionized so 87% are like Dennis where
there are small independent firms mhm
and a lot of them actually
bought or leased their own trucks so
they took out tens of thousands of
dollars in the equivalent of a mortgage
to get this truck and so if they have to
compete against a robot truck that
doesn't stop that's like you know that's
existential level stuff yeah and right
now truck drivers have time use
regulations where they cannot drive more
than 14 hours a day so you can't you
literally cannot compete right because
the robot trucks just gonna keep going
our 15 16 17 yeah etc so these guys make
some of them make really good money like
some of them make 70 75 80 thousand
dollars it's one of the higher paying
jobs for men without a you know college
degree and so if you look at what
they're facing it's not so crazy that
they're like hey you need to make the
robots illegal because for them what is
the next best economic alternative if
the robot trucks take over that job like
what they go from yeah it's not crazy
for them but it's a crazy idea to tell a
company that they can't do something
that's more efficient safer than
probably economically more viable
oh yeah again the savings from
automating truck driving are estimated
to be a hundred sixty eight billion
dollars per year and not just labor
savings but also equipment utilization
because the trucks never stop fuel
efficiency because the trucks can
daisy-chain together so there's less
wind resistance mhm fewer accidents
because right now truck accidents kill
about four thousand people a year so you
probably save lives there's a very very
powerful argument for the fact that we
should be trying to automate this stuff
yeah but on the other side you have
literally three and a half million
truckers who rely upon this for their
livelihoods to support their family and
there's gonna be a lot of passion a lot
of resistance to this anyone who thinks
that truck drivers are just gonna shrug
and be like alright I guess I had a good
run I'm just gonna go home and figure it
out that's not gonna be their response
right it's gonna be much more likely
that they say you need to make these
robot trucks illegal or they're just
gonna park their trucks across the
highway get their guns out because a lot
of these guys are ex-military and just
be like hey like I'm not moving my truck
until you know I get my job back and
there'll be a lot of truckers in the
same situation you really think that
would happen well I think we blocked the
highway for their job back that's less
efficient kills more people so I was
with these truckers in the truck stop in
Altoona Iowa and Joe they have really
really difficult jobs I mean I don't
know if you knew truckers where you were
but they're they have this 14 hour
window where they're allowed to drive
their truck and they drive most of that
so they have these other ten hours and
they sleep in their truck the trucks
have a bed they go into the truck stop
they take a shower and there's a laundry
and they're like plugged into this
machine of this truck of an end the
industry you know they spend days
sometimes weeks on the road a lot of
them listen to podcasts probably a lot
of them listening right now a lot of
them listen to podcasts and they're
doing it primarily because it's a more
lucrative opportunity than the other
jobs that are available to them a lot of
them have families that like you know
like supporting their families and so if
you say hey guys like you know times up
for this way of life most of them I
think will not like like
I look at how much they frankly they
like injurer there's so much endurance
baked into that job yeah that I think
most of them will be like some of the
guys you and I know where they're much
more likely to like implode or like you
know do something where where it's
self-destructive than they would be to
take their truck in you know park it
across the highway hmm but you're
talking about a population of hundreds
of thousands including many small
business owners and small business
owners have a different mentality very
often like I've been an entrepreneur I'm
a serial entrepreneur for like last 20
years like you're an entrepreneur and if
you saw this happen you might say hey
I'm adaptable I'll figure it out or you
might say hey I think I can do something
about this like if I park my truck this
way like that's going to cause such
havoc that it's you know it's like
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
economic harm very very fast and if you
look at the Industrial Revolution which
people cite as the precursor to what
we're going through there were mass
riots in the industrial revolution that
killed dozens of people caused billions
of dollars worth of damage Labor Day is
a holiday today because of those riots
and then we implemented universal high
school in nineteen eleven in part as a
response to these riots so according to
the estimates this is called the fourth
Industrial Revolution and we're going to
displace jobs at three to four times the
rate of that Industrial Revolution and
that Industrial Revolution included mass
riots so thinking that this one will not
strikes me as really really optimistic
and perhaps unrealistic mmm what do you
see coming when when you when you think
that these jobs are going to be
automated and then universal basic
income is going to supplement their in
it's gonna give them some money $1,000 a
month but where do they go from there I
mean how do people exist on twelve
thousand dollars a year like what do
they do like how do they adapt to this
new world right so the first thing you
have to do is you have to look at what
lies ahead if we do nothing right so the
the way it's going to play out is that
self-driving trucks are slowly going to
start Hina
waise amazon's testing them out right
now and the first stage is going to be
that there is a human driver just
sitting there as a fail-safe and the
trucks going to drive itself now my
friends in Silicon Valley are working on
tella operators which is so the trucks
have right now like a 98% accuracy level
which is not very high because you can't
have 2% semi trucks like running into
things so the way they're trying to get
the last percent or so is they're
equipping trucks with tella operating
software which means that a trucker a
tella operator in Nevada or Arizona will
beam into the truck and just be able to
see out the front like a video game like
let you know it's like drone operating
but instead is a truck and right you
beam in and then you just steer the
truck and tell the computers like I got
it from here and then you beam out
that's what they're working on to try
and get catch that last bit of
uncertainty so the innovations are
having it again Joe we're talking about
one hundred sixty eight billion dollars
a year like everything becomes possible
when you're looking at that much money
so in the absence of anyone doing
anything the robot trucks will start
reducing shifts of various truckers I
would say six to ten years from now and
so then there'll be a bunch of reactions
now trucking firms already have massive
shortages they can't find enough people
that's one reason why they're trying to
automate this job as fast as they are
because they're literally like you know
they're short like a couple hundred
thousand truckers right now and people
don't want to go into this field for a
variety of reasons the main thing being
it's like extraordinarily brutal on you
physically very very bad for your family
life - because you're away all the time
yeah something like 88% of truckers have
an early marker for chronic disease like
oh you know like substance abuse
diabetes obesity high blood pressure so
along those lines and now people think
that the jobs going to disappear in the
next five to ten years you can't get
people in so if you play out what
happens when the robot trucks start
reducing shifts then there'll be people
trying to flee the field of trucking and
then if it becomes really dramatic where
the robots start driving let's say
between western
yeah and Nevada and then human beings
get in in those states and then take it
the rest of the way because the robots
won't be reliable enough to drive in
urban areas
they'll be reliable enough to drive on
an interstate but they just have to make
a few decisions then there'll be a
massive depletion of truck driving
opportunities and then in my mind a lot
of suicides a lot of self destruction
and I don't say that lightly I say that
based upon the fact that that's what
happened the manufacturing workers where
if you unpack what happened to the
manufacturing workers of Michigan Ohio
Indiana suicide rates spiked to a point
where now our life expectancy as a
country has declined for the last three
years because of suicides and drug
overdoses it's the first time that's
happened since the great flu pandemic of
1918 like we are actually coming apart
as a country by the numbers so what
happened to the manufacturing workers
will then happen to the trucker's but at
a even more dramatic scale so you'll see
truckers going home and drinking
themselves to death or doing drugs and
overdosing or killing themselves and
then eventually there'll be an outbreak
of violence because some truckers will
say instead of killing myself how about
I go bust up a robot truck and there are
already truckers that are doing things
like blocking Tesla recharging stations
and electronic vehicle battery stations
because they don't like electronic
trucks sword
those are pickup trucks though those are
[ __ ] I mean this is not like people
doing it because they they think that
these tesla recharge stations are taking
jobs away they're just being [ __ ]
exactly Jo so if you're gonna be a
[ __ ] even though it really has
nothing to do with you right imagine
when you actually think your livelihood
is being threatened then you can see it
getting revved up you know to like a
much higher level yeah so so I'm running
for president in large part because I
think we need to get in front of this
set of problems we have to say look if
we're gonna save a hundred sixty eight
billion dollars a year maybe some of
that should go to the truckers and give
them a soft landing maybe we should have
this universal basic income where
everyone feels like they're getting a
thousand bucks a month which is
out-of-work replacement it's not gonna
make their lives easy they still need to
work but at least it takes the edge off
it takes like the existential threat off
and also their kids getting it so they
feel like okay my kid actually has some
kind of path to the future and it's not
like if I lose this trucking job not
only am I going to you know struggle and
suffer but my kid will too so my plan as
president is to install a trucker
transitions are and say look it is your
job to try and manage this transition
for the three and a half million
truckers in Joe we haven't even talked
about the five million Americans who
work at truckstops motels diners retail
establishments all the places where the
truckers stop every day just to get out
eat a meal and you know like live a life
I mean if you imagine those communities
when the trucks don't stop there's gonna
be a drying up of economic vitality on a
level that's unprecedented in many of
these communities this is something that
I I'm just becoming aware of over the
last year or two how when when you are
out on the campaign trail and you know
you're talking to media and you're
discussing this with people how many
people have no idea that this is coming
well what I say to people Joe is I say
have you noticed store is closing on
your Main Street and then they say yes
and I asked them why is that
and then they reflect for a minute and
then they say Amazon and I'm like yeah
that's right it was getting twenty
billion dollars of commerce every year
and it's now tipping your malls and Main
Street stories into oblivion you know
and like is that gonna get better or
worse because so some people say it's
like hobb the robots like the robots are
yours away and then you're like no it's
not robots actually like walking around
your neighborhood I mean of course
that's unlikely but Amazon soaking up
the business that used to go to your
mall if you go to their fulfillment
center it's robots as far as the eye can
see if you go to their their warehouse
you know it's also robots as far as far
as the eye can see so when you ask how
aware are people that this is happening
it's one of those truths that as soon as
you pointed out they're like oh yeah
like I I knew that was what was up it's
just for whatever reason I'm like the
only person just laying out the facts
and being like guys it's not your
imagination like we actually are getting
rid of the most common jobs in the US
economy
filled by high school graduates and then
replacing them with a handful of jobs
for higher skilled people in different
places and then we're pretending that
the first population is somehow gonna
access the new opportunities when the
odds of them getting up and like moving
to Seattle or whatnot and becoming a web
designer or like logistics manager or a
big data scientist or something like
essentially near zero and so this is
what gave rise to a lot of the anger
that got Donald Trump elected because
they looked around their communities and
we're like hey I used to work in this
manufacturing plant this manufacturing
plant no longer exists for whatever
reason like I'm being told that it's
somehow like my fault that I wasn't
adaptable enough like I did you know I
didn't somehow become a coders or
something ridiculous then I have to say
Joanne this is like something that I've
picked up from Dennis in part so I'm
with this trucker in Iowa and he says to
me he says like I don't think that
Democrats care about people like me
and he says that to me while I'm in his
truck and I'm just like I can understand
why he feels that way but that's
incredibly destructive because there's a
point at which Democratic Party used to
be very very heavily aligned with
working-class Americans and there's now
some kind of pathology that if the
person who's suffering is a white man of
a certain background than the suffering
somehow is like somehow like diminished
it doesn't count as much if they're a
trucker and that's something that I find
really destructive it's like we have to
start acknowledging the source of the
problems one thing I'm saying to people
is like look it's not immigrants that
are taking these jobs away like just
facts it is not immigrants it is the
fact that technology is pushing our
economy in a direction that makes it
harder and harder for many Americans to
get by based upon this current I trade
my time for money model now truckers
seem to be the big one right yeah
cashiers are another one
yeah what are the other job that jobs
that are going to be killed by
automation so the the next obvious one
is call center workers of course where
there are two and a half million call
center workers still in the United
States generally high school graduates
that make about $14 an hour now when you
and I call a company we're like pounding
Keys trying to get a human because the
AI is so annoying yeah you know it's
like hey but you know just like give me
give me a person yeah
but over the next number of months AI is
going to become industry
indistinguishable from a person yeah
like the new Google answering service
yeah that comes with the pixel phone so
it's amazing yes
and so that two and a half million call
center population is gonna shrink a ton
because after you get AI software that's
better than one of them you know it can
be most all of them you know it's not
like 5,000 jobs that's potentially
500,000 jobs right I was at a conference
of CEOs and I asked how many of them are
looking at having AI replaced back
office workers like various clerical
functions every single hand went up
there's going to be a lot of clerical
work having systems talk to each other
that's going to disappear and one CIO
type of like a major bank said that his
estimate was that's about 30 percent of
the bank's workers fall into that
category so you're looking at call
center workers you're looking at back
office workers you're looking at
insurance brokers insurance is a very
highly automated industry because it's a
lot of information getting passed back
and forth cashiers as you said truck
drivers delivery drivers uber drivers I
heard that it goes even as far as
medical procedures there was a recent
automated medical procedure where they
did surgery on a grape yes yeah I see
that yeah I saw that
and China has already had just a
complete automated dental implant ation
because China actually has a real
shortage of surgeons and so their
incentives to try and automate this are
very very high now the interesting thing
here Joe is that let's say I made a
robot surgeon tomorrow that was awesome
could do better work than a lot of
people mm-hmm
right now the economic incentive still
are not necessarily for everyone to use
my robot surgeon because the regulations
aren't there
yet in the US and so healthcare is a
really interesting one another one
that's very clearly going to get taken
up by AI is radiology and looking at
tumors on a film because it turns out
that a I can see shades of grey that a
human eye cannot mmm and it can
reference millions of films where the
most experienced doctor can probably
reference thousands and so radiology
I'll tell you medical students are
running from radiology as fast they can
because they know that's gonna get taken
up by AI man this is it's such a bleak
forecast it's very strange when we stop
and think about all the different things
that human beings find value in as far
as their occupation like hey imma this
AMA that is what I do and the idea that
these things are all gonna go away it's
very it's kind of disturbing oh and when
I was digging into the research show
it's been happening and it's tearing us
apart I mean I referenced the fact that
so here are some things that are all
tied halt all time are multi decade
highs right now in the United States of
America suicide drug overdoses anxiety
and depression mental problems financial
and security people being unable to pay
their bills all of these things are at
record highs and one thing III know
you've talked about in the past that I
think you'd really find fascinating so
there's been there have been studies as
to what happens to your mind when you
can't pay your bills and and when you
can't pay your bills you're like
stressing out it's like if I pay this I
can't pay that and there's like always
the time money trade-off it's like oh if
I spend extra time commuting maybe I can
save a couple bucks and so what it does
is it actually constrains your bandwidth
to a point that your functional IQ goes
down by 13 points or one standard
deviation so just if you say to someone
hey here's a bill you can't pay and then
you give them IQ test it their score
actually goes down by 13 points along
that's like a really huge if now and so
what we're doing right now Joe is we're
actually making our population less
rational less reasonable more impulsive
more subject to bad ideas nastier more
subject to things like racism and
misogyny too because it turns out what
happens with most of us is you need
executive functioning to resist like
racist and massage massage
mystic impulses and so if I make you
cash-strapped and make it so you can't
pay your bills you're actually more
likely to be like yeah like yeah like
blame them so what what we're talking
about again it's not this speculative
future it's that we've been doing this
for years and it's actually pushing our
population into a mindset of scarcity of
nastiness and that's why universal basic
income is so crucial because it gets the
boot off of people's throats and it
replaces the mindset of scarcity with a
mindset of abundance
and rationality and optimism and
capacity like I'm an entrepreneur you're
an entrepreneur I'll tell you very very
few entrepreneurs start businesses at a
scarcity where they're like oh I can't
pay my bills I guess I'm not like start
a new company like most of them but
$1,000 a month is even enough money for
most people to pay for their rent well
the great thing is again this thousand
dollars is yours no matter what so right
now let's say you're you're doing a
normal job so if you make a million
dollars a year you still get a thousand
dollars a month yes yes you do I mean
it's opt-in so you could opt in and take
it which most Americans would because it
still a thousand bucks a month yeah
people get greedy yeah sure
yeah thousand dollars to get my nails
done yes yeah or give it away if they
were you know they felt like it yeah
yeah but that the this so those are the
things that are at like all-time highs
is like all these negative social
indicators here things that are at
all-time lows getting married starting a
business having a kid moving for a new
job all of those things are at historic
lows in the United States of America
having children really yeah we're at
record low birth rates right now and
it's largely because people feel too
strapped to have kids I mean that's
literally where we are when you say
record low by like what percentage you
can look up right now Jamie I know if
you want to look this up but stories
have come out over this last year saying
that Americans are now at the lowest
rate of child birth that has been the
case and decades or ever yeah that's a
conversation that I have with people
whenever they say that they're worried
about population but the population is
growing so fast and over popular here
goes one point
eight-zero births per woman 2016 what
does that mean
so stropping yeah just from 1970 at a
high - yeah what seems fairly fairly
similar from 1980 to today that still
love if it goes from 1.8 tell like if it
goes from even something like 1.9 to 1.8
is like a pretty significant drop there
it wasn't us birth dip to 30 or low hmm
fertility rates sink further below
replacement level and so you think so
but the thought is that this is because
of Education and that this is because if
people are waiting longer to have
children and that this is a byproduct of
industrialization and modern world and
that the more educated and affluent
people get the less likely they are to
have children then it's not the sign as
far as what everything I've read about
it is that that it's not a symptom of
people doing poorly it's a symptom of
people doing well you know there there
are definitely cases where richer
countries just have fewer kids yeah
that's cool cuz they concentrate on
their careers right not the idea but the
the darker part of this Jo is that right
now if you're a non college educated
person in the United States the odds of
you are ever getting married less than
50% no for the first time ever and then
people are having fewer kids to play
devil's advocate though the the marriage
thing might be people looking at it and
go god my parents got divorced my
brother got divorced everybody else got
divorced what the [ __ ] am i doing there
are a lot of good reasons for it you
know as a happily married man you know
me as well I was talking don't do it I
tell people don't do it it's just it's
too risky
yeah so so you could look at to me
certainly to me getting married and
having kids like an act of like
prosperity or optimism there are reasons
why it's going down otherwise but if you
look at things like starting a new
business I mean that being at
multi-decade lows there's like no
positive spin on that right people
moving between states is now at
multi-decade lows people moving for a
new job multi-decade lows like I think
this is the product of automation or
it's the product of a bunch of different
factors like
internet but purchasing and marketing
and think people buying most of their
goods and it's a range of factors but
one of the big problems and keep in mind
I spent seven years helping
entrepreneurs grow businesses in 18
cities around the country between 2011
2017 that was actually my job my job was
to be the job creator guy hmm and so
when you go out to these places you see
that the dynamism is getting sucked up
by certain markets to a level that's
unprecedented in our history like that
that the disparities between Cleveland
and San Francisco or st. Louis in LA are
much much higher than they've been at
any other historical period both by the
numbers and like after you actually go
to the places you're like wow like this
is not flourishing the way that you'd
hope do you feel like an economic Paul
Revere in a certain sense like the
robots are coming the robots are coming
I do
it's weird man what the comparison I
make is that if the United States
economy is like an elephant
you know the parable of like the people
like you know blind people you know
touching the elephant mm-hmm
so I'm an entrepreneur I sold a company
to a public company that was a national
education company is based in New York
what is the parable of blind people
touching an elephant so what happens is
they're they're like seven blind men and
they they get asked like what is the
what does an elephant look like and then
one of them is touching the trunk and is
like an elephant looks like a snake and
another one's touching its leg and it's
like an elephant looks like a tree trunk
so that's the way most people experience
the economy is that they're like
touching a part of the economy and
they're like this is what it looks like
I mean like so I've had this really
strange set of experiences where I sold
a national education company to a public
company
I lived bicoastal II between New York
and San Francisco for the last five
years I've operated in 18 cities around
the country I was a I was an appointee
in the Obama administration in DC so
I've actually seen the elephant if you
know what I mean hmm like a whole
elephant yeah like I'm like hanging out
with the tech wizards in Silicon Valley
and I'm like hey you know we can
automate these jobs and they're like oh
yeah we're not I mean you know so it's
not a mystery and then
bad people it's like hey it's my job to
like matter and if you gave me a choice
between making things work better and
creating abundant opportunities for the
other people I would choose that but I
do not have that choice I have a job to
do you know this is my job and what I
tell people is like who's responsibility
then is it to go tell the people look
it's technology it's transforming the
economy in fundamental ways and we need
to make it so that everyone benefits and
it's not just that this like hyper
concentrated set of winners and then
it's like huge army of relative losers
and it's the government's job but at
this point we've given up on our
government as anything like it can't
really do anything and so now it's
no-one's job and so somehow Joe it has
become my job and it blows my mind to
sometimes now coming from a place of
being a serial entrepreneur to this
presidential candidate he's kind of
warning people about the upcoming
technological apocalypse as it were how
did you make that transition and what
was your motivation to get involved in
this to the point we were actually
running for president on this platform
yeah so so sell a company in 2009 and
that was the financial crisis like Wall
Street it crashed the economy and I had
personally taught these kids who'd
worked at Goldman Sachs and Morgan
Stanley and and McKenzie and I was like
man we need smart kids to do something
other than just head to Wall Street in
Silicon Valley we need to have them go
to Detroit st. Louis Baltimore and
awhile and start businesses so I quit my
job I donated low six figures to start
this new organization and then we
trained hundreds of entrepreneurs and
helped create several thousand jobs so
that was like my wholesome give back I
was like hey I'm like you know the guy
who just believes in entrepreneurship
because just like you I freaking love
entrepreneurs and I was like so here's
the joke I used to tell I went to law
school I was an unhappy lawyer for five
months and so what I tell people is like
if you're a clueless ambitious 22 year
old who came out of college and you say
to your parents hey I'm gonna go to law
school they're gonna say that's great
it's really easy to find the law school
because they're just apply to it and the
government will give you a hundred
thousand dollar loan no quest
and then if you say to your parents hey
I want to be an entrepreneur
your parents will think that's stupid
it's hard to find and no one's gonna
give you a hundred thousand dollar loan
so we have this huge oversupply of
indebted Law School graduates and a huge
under supply of entrepreneurs was my
thinking and so I was like okay how do
you fix that
so I started this organization venture
for America to try and fix that and so
imagine being this guy getting medals
and awards for helping create jobs
around the country and then realizing
that automation is coming like a tidal
wave and that your efforts that you're
getting applauded for are really not
gonna do the trick and then Donald Trump
wins the election in 2016 and for
whatever reason in my opinion the media
is not being honest about all the
economic drivers they're blaming racism
Russia Facebook the FBI and if you look
at the voter district data on a
district-by-district basis there's a
straight line up between the adoption of
industrial robots in that voting
district and the movement towards Trump
mmm like it's a straight economic story
where we blasted away four million
manufacturing jobs in the swing states
and Donald Trump is our president so
imagine being me and then seeing that
and being like okay I get it this is an
economic technological story and then I
went to people in Washington DC I was
like hey guys what are we gonna do we're
in the third inning of the greatest
economic and technological
transformation in the history of our
country and the third inning has brought
us Donald Trump the fourth fifth six
things are going to be horrific what are
we gonna do and then the answers I got
were somewhere between disappointing and
horrifying where if you go to mainstream
politicians and you're like what are we
gonna do the answers I got were
literally number one we cannot talk
about that number two we should study
that we cannot talk about that was
that's verbatim really yeah and why were
they saying that because it seems
alarmist like anti-progress or like you
know you're like you know throwing
stones at like like big tech companies
and it's like I'm not throwing stones at
anyone I'm just pointing out the fact so
number one is so number one was can't
talk about it
number two was need to study it
number three was the point you made
originally which was we must educate and
retrain Americans for the jobs of the
future and then when I was like hey
we're terrible at that by the numbers
yeah
then they'd literally be like well I
guess we'll learn to get better at it
then and then I so I came back to my
home in New York City and I was like oh
my gosh like we are so backward and far
gone as certainly as a government and so
then I was grappling with it and I'm a
parent like you are and I looked at my
kids and I was like am I really gonna
bring them up in this [ __ ] show like and
so then I was like okay how would you
actually solve this problem if you if
you had to do so and so then I said okay
universal basic income rebranded the
freedom dividend after we did a bunch of
tests cuz it tests much better as the
freedom dividend the universal basic
income and and then try and make the
rules of the economy work better for
more people as fast as we can before
this automation wave really crescendos
what do you mean by that well to me like
you know what I'm saying is like retail
and truck driving are the two major
major obvious sectors that are going to
get displaced being a retail worker is
the most common job in the United States
right now the average retail worker is a
39 year old woman with a high school
education making between 11 and 12
dollars an hour so what do those workers
do when 30% of the malls and stores
close in the next five years you know
and then truckers are next in line you
know by the five to ten year mark so I
was like we have to get our acts
together before these populations end up
getting displaced and we know Americans
don't have a ton of savings to fall back
on it's not like they'll be like oh like
you know let me take a month off to like
think about it but that's not the real
life situation most Americans live in
experience so so this is all 2017 where
I'm like doing the data research and
saying like okay like what's the plan
and then when I went to various
politicians I was like there is no
appetite for making this case there's no
appetite for anyone even talking about
this so the only thing I can see that
would have a realistic chance of
accelerating meaningful solutions to
this automation wave in a five to ten
year time frame is if I run for
president and I either win which is very
doable I can win or I mainstream this
set of considerations to a point where
other politicians are willing to tackle
something like universal basic income
and make it a reality in that timeframe
anyone can win right I mean it is
possible I mean there are voters people
are voting but do you really believe
that you can win well Joe I wouldn't be
running if you wouldn't right I believe
that but but if you were not you know I
I appreciate the question and I've been
very upfront the whole time is that if
my ideas and policies become front and
center and we get this done then if I'm
not pres the United States like I'm
perfectly happy with that like I'm on
the record just being like I'm just
trying to solve problems I'm an
entrepreneur trying to solve a problem
that said I'm already pulling at one
percent nationally I'm tied with Kirsten
Gillibrand and other national
politicians right now as we're sitting
here I have no idea
Kirsti you Kirsten Gillibrand she's a
senator from New York national
politician normal morons like myself are
not aware of that like I wouldn't have
known that you were running if it wasn't
for Sam yeah I appreciate that man but
now happily everyone who's a fan of
yours which is apparently everybody
knows of Ruddick but so you're you're
right that most people have never heard
of Andrew yang and I'm already pulling
at 1% enough for me to make the debates
are you running as an independent I'm
running as a Democrat because the
mechanics make it such that that is
necessary for you to be able to actually
succeed and win hmm but I can go through
with you the mechanics and you might
enjoy this because I know you you and
Sam and others sometimes talk politics
and presidential politics so I'm an
operator I'm an entrepreneur and so you
get to and be like okay what does it
take to be president so there are two
rules to run for president one is you
have to be 35 years or older check and
then the second is natural-born citizen
check only rules that's it so then you
get into the process and you say okay
the first two states to vote are Iowa
and New Hampshire now they're gonna be
about 20 people running for president as
a Democrat this cycle you probably knew
that right mm-hmm
so you look at the Iowa caucus Iowa has
a population of 3.1 million but only one
hundred seventy-one thousand Iowans
participated in the caucus in 2016
because it's a very high investment now
they change the rules so this year it's
going to be closer to like let's call it
250,000 but if you have 20 candidates to
finish top three in a field at twenty
you probably need about 40 to 50,000
Iowans to get on board so you say hey do
do I think I can be present United
States the threshold question is this
can I get 40 to 50,000 Iowans on board
with the idea that them and their family
members getting $1,000 a month is a good
idea that that would actually help
improve their lives well I'm sure it
would help improve their lives and I'm
sure they would agree with you the
question is what are the other thing you
know see I don't think most people are
aware that this is coming and I think
you people and explaining all these
statistics and seeing the forecast
particularly from your position as a
serial entrepreneur who has a deep
background in business and you have a
deep understanding of this you're
helping in a tremendous way by educating
people but I think most people have it
maybe logically but they have different
concerns so how do you address these
other concerns like I bet if you polled
people what are the issues what are the
issues in this upcoming 2020
presidential race that you know who's
going to beat Donald Trump how do you do
it
this is like on the Democratic side the
idea is like anyone but Trump right yeah
this is I mean they would be so happy if
filming blank Tulsi Gabbard you whoever
on the Republican side obviously it's
Trump unless someone comes along or he
goes to jail those are the two
possibilities
yeah what are the other issues and that
you feel that people are really
concerned about that you can perhaps
shed some unique light on sure so the
the three big policy as I'm running on
are one the freedom dividend because a
lot of Americans are seeing their
paychecks not keep up with their
expenses number two is we need to get
health care off the backs of businesses
and families and move towards a
single-payer system
medicare-for-all because as an
entrepreneur it makes it harder to hire
people when you do hire people you want
to make them contractors and not
full-time employees it makes it harder
for people to start businesses because
they're concerned about keeping their
health care for their families so we got
to get health care off the backs of
businesses and families and trying to
make the economy more dynamic and we
spend twice as much on health care as
other countries do to worst results like
it's right now we're in like the worst
of all worlds and the third thing is and
I referenced my wife when I talk about
this my wife is at home with our two
boys six and three one of whom is
autistic and when I say is like what is
her work value that in GDP and then
people think about and I like I don't
know and I'm like zero GDP like doesn't
consider that actual economic
contribution and then I say we have to
do is we have to actually evolve from
GDP as a measuring stick because it
actually doesn't work for us it's almost
a hundred years old we made it up during
the Great Depression self-driving trucks
are gonna drive GDP way up but it's
gonna be very very bad for many people
and communities so we have to actually
change the measuring sticks to something
that would actually make our economy
work for us make it so that the market
serves us instead of all us being inputs
to the market because if we're all
inputs to the market we lose to robots
in AI hands down and it's not like it
doesn't matter if you were like a really
conscientious hard-working truck driver
like a really lazy sloppy it doesn't
matter like you know doesn't matter if
you were like a really diligent
radiologist or like it doesn't matter so
we have to shift the markets emphasis to
actually fuel our well-being and change
from GDP which is again this archaic
measurement we made up to to things that
would actually correspond to how we're
doing things like health how childhood
success rates environmental how do you
quantify that how do you how would you
quantify that in a way that would be
translatable to the average voter yeah
so we have measurements for most of
these things and and again if you look
at our numbers right now you'd see it's
like what like how many people listen
with this know that America's life
expectancy has declined for the last
three years you know that to me would be
like a pretty important measurement but
you think that's because of is it
because the suicide is it because of
drug overdoses
because of obesity diet what is it
the the two causes that people point to
the most are that drug overdoses and
suicides have overtaken vehicular deaths
as as the most frequent deaths in the
United States I didn't know that suicide
was Lois I knew that drug overdose had
taken obesity but suicides of overtaking
obesity as well suicides have overtaken
car accidents I'm not sure about it I'm
sorry I meant I meant car accidents I
misspoke so car accidents used to be
number one yeah
suicides are higher than car accidents
now yeah so suicides drug overdoses and
then car accidents like or suicides and
drug overdoses like I think drug
overdose is number one number one and
then suicides number two Wow
and so that's why life expectancy has
declined for all and you think that the
Tsuen very much likely there's at least
some of the number of the suicides are
related to economic disparity oh yeah I
mean if you look at the suicide rate in
it's particularly pronounced in 50 to 50
year old
50 to 54 year old white Americans which
are the population I mean you resemble
that that's me
yeah that's you which resembles the
population that right now is just
reaching a point where they're like hey
my job skills don't have any you know
like utility in the marketplace and then
they go home and they just like you know
start looking around and being like what
am i doing I mean it's it's really dark
it's punitive it's punishing and we've
put our citizens in the situation where
we all see ourselves as economic inputs
what the market says we're worth is what
we're worth and if we're worth less then
it's our fault and so the next move is
to say okay I guess you know this place
there's no place for me here I don't
mean it sounds skeptical but I just
don't believe that a thousand dollars in
a month is gonna fix that it seems like
that would be a good thing
certainly not moving in the wrong
direction certainly moving in the right
direction but it seems that there needs
to be some sort of a massive rethinking
of civilization itself if you're gonna
have that many things that are going to
be automated and that many people are
going to be out of
and feeling that the world that they
prepared for no longer exists yes it
seems like we need a step further
another move a hundred percent brother
and that's one reason why the freedom
dividends not like us like a that
doesn't solve the problem right the
problem is fundamentally one of
reconstituting means of structure
purpose and fulfillment in people's
lives particularly in men's lives right
how do we do that
right so one important aspect of that is
to actually start measuring how we are
doing as a society and saying that's
actually where we're trying to go so
instead of using GDP using some sort of
other quantifiable method of measuring
health and happiness and fulfillment yes
levels of engagement with work hmm in
mental health I mean you can we have
measurements for that we are
sophisticated enough to do that and then
if we say then as president I'm gonna be
up there in 2021 being like oh here's
the state of the union here's like the
data and then we're gonna say you don't
want to try and do we're actually going
to try and move those measurements in
the right direction so let's try and get
drug overdoses down by 50% in two years
let's try and get our mental health up a
little bit like in in these ways and
then make it so that that person who's
at home being like okay like you know
like there's not a job for me I'm
getting a thousand bucks a month that
does not solve all my problems it takes
the edge off but then we can hopefully
start reconstituting what that person's
purpose is in their community in their
neighborhood and so one of the things
that I'm going to point out is that if
you pump a thousand bucks a month into
that neighborhood it ends up creating a
whole new rung of opportunities for the
people in that community like some of
that money goes to you know like youth
leagues and churches and nonprofits and
creates jobs right there in that
community one of the examples I use is
like if you're in a town in Missouri
with 50,000 people and let's say you
really like to bake but starting a
bakery is a dumb idea because people
just do not have money in that town to
buy your baked goods but then I pump see
ten million dollars a year into that
economy and a lot of that just
circulates right there in that town then
if I start a bakery it's a good idea and
I know if my bakery fails I'm not going
to die I can at least go home and get my
dividend and then if I go to other
people and say hey you want to like help
me out with this then they also think
it's a better idea than they would have
so the money is not the solution the
money helps set the stage for the
solutions and so does the measurements
so does if you because right now if like
you don't even know that your life
expectancy is declining that's kind of
hard to solve that problem so if you say
look this is actually how we measure how
we're doing and then you go in and say
okay like local government NGO
entrepreneur because right now like our
entrepreneurs
none of our entrepreneurs are working on
trying to make that dudes life better
you know it's like that's not only do so
much most entrepreneurs are just trying
to succeed I mean it's very difficult to
start a business right and actually have
it work out well the the idea that
they're gonna look out for truck drivers
yeah it's not realistic but it at least
we can start moving ourselves in that
general direction if we start because as
a CEO you know this you make what you
measure mm you're not measuring it you
have no chance right if you start
measuring it you at least start to open
up the chance but what you're saying is
the most profound which is like we need
to reconstitute meaning for many many
Americans yeah and that's what to me the
most destructive aspect of that you know
again like the mental health indicators
and like the suicides and the rest of it
is like there's a real loss of meaning
for many many people here in this
country well obviously we're talking
about a large scale but if you go back
to the time before trucks and truck
drivers that was not a viable occupation
it wasn't something people did but yet
they still found a way to occupy their
time do you think that there needs to be
some sort of an education and some some
sort of a method of explaining to young
people in particular that you have to
think of something to do because most of
the things that you think you can do
won't exist so we have to think of what
are the other possibilities and be
creative
and do something with your life that
only a human being can do which is a
really weird way to think about it
because most of the things you used to
be able to think that a human being
could do for a living are now going to
be done by robots
but I don't think I think there's a
giant gap between the understanding that
you have and the understanding that the
average person has and this could be a
real problem and trying to expand this
platform well we have to inform I gotta
tell you though Joe when I say this to
people they're like that makes perfect
yeah it does make perfect sense that's
scary about it but I'm not I'm not
disagreeing with you in any way shape or
form I'm just thinking man for young
kids for young kids and you know you're
a parent I'm a parent but what so our
education system has a lot to be desired
and one of the things I'm saying is like
is it's making all these kids think that
college is the end-all be-all and it is
not you know and so that's one issue is
that we need to try and prepare kids for
different kinds of paths instead of
saying college college college yeah
because they're going to college they're
getting loaded up with record levels of
debt college has gotten two-and-a-half
times more expensive even though it has
not gotten two-and-a-half times better
and the reason why it's gotten so
expensive is because they've just like
gotten really bloated administrative Lea
and what would you do about that like
you know Bernie Sanders wants to have
some sort of a free college Free
University yeah who wants to do it
across the board have education to be a
hundred percent free yeah I mean look I
love that on paper I one of the things
that I hate is talking to my friends
about college debt you know friends that
are in their 30s and 40s around yeah it
just it just stays with them like a wet
blanket that you can never get out of I
used to call my school loans my mistress
because I was writing a check to like
another family in another town I was
like I hope they're enjoying themselves
like nine hundred dollars about to buy
loans and what's crazy is that if
something devastating happens to you in
any other form you can file for
bankruptcy but you never escape your
student loans no matter what happens to
you that was just some lobbying on the
part of the financial companies man
there's a lot to her
is dirty that's really dirty when you
think about how many people that run
corporations that have racked up I mean
just think about what happened with the
savings and loan crisis just lately man
and those guys skated whoo you know the
vast majority have they're carrying
around zero zero burden from that
yes vast majority no one went to jail
set a few people not really anybody real
criminals like Bernie Madoff went to
jail you know a few people have but
that's about it you know you'd have to
be a real [ __ ] thief to go to jail
and these people that just they did this
and got away with it and profited and
redistributed all this money into their
own personal accounts and economy
sideways yeah but heaven forbid you take
out a bunch of school loans and things
go south like you can't get out of it I
mean I know a guy who's in his 50s who's
an ophthalmologist who's deeply in debt
still so raising yeah it is crazy and if
you look at it just economically it's a
massive burden YES on people starting
businesses starting families buying
homes with their parents it's possible
to fix for sure
so the the first thing you do is you go
to the people that are currently in debt
and say look we're gonna give you a path
out and there are ways to do it you know
you can have a payment plan one of the
things I'm proposing is like a 10 by 10
where if you commit 10% your wages for
10 years and you're debt-free and that
means like if you're not making a lot of
money then you can save a whole lot and
the schools at this point have long
since forgotten about this these loans
because they got paid off already
this is just these financial companies
that are holding the loans that's
important for people to understand
because people think well you don't pay
them the colleges are gonna go away no
no so if you're the government you can
be like hey loan loan company guess what
like good news we're gonna like take
this off it's a stimulus because like
you said we've done a lot of things that
were supposed to be a stimulus like give
four trillion dollars to the banks and
be like that will stimulate the economy
nothing's gonna stimulate the economy
better than getting student loans off
the backs of freaking young people
they'll actually do what they're
supposed to do which is actually you
know spend money in the economy take
chance to take chances our businesses
and the rest of it I mean one of the
reasons why our
business formation rates are at
multi-decade lows that we are up to 1.5
trillion dollars in school debt it's
like 38 K ahead that was like a hundred
billion in like 1999 so we've like gone
up 15 X since then and it's crippling us
it's like insane anyone who thinks that
that's not burning the economy I mean
it's got a so president yang will be
like hey guys it's a stimulus but this
time to stimulus at people we're gonna
forgive some of the student loan debt
because half that stuff was generated in
morally anyway a lot of uses schools you
know lying about just to get people in
the door that the second thing you do is
you go to the schools and say hey guys
why are you two-and-a-half times more
expensive than you used to be that's
kind of weird because like as far as I
can tell there's been no massive quality
change and the reason is that they've
hired a lot of administrators it has not
gone to faculty it has not gone to
facilities it has gone to just
administrative excess and bloat and then
say okay you can do whatever you want
but if you want access to federal loans
which they all rely upon for their
life's blood like without it they die if
you want your students have access to
federal loans you have to bring your
administrator to student ratio in line
with what it was like in the 1990s and
then the schools would scream bloody
murder they'd be like I can't do that
that's impossible you're like well I
have a feeling you're gonna figure it
out start bringing it down and you would
realize it doesn't impact the student
experience at all like and I understand
it because I've run a large nonprofit
organization that it started and you're
very natural tendency is to hire
excellent people and then before you
know it you're like have excellent
people like you know vice deans of
everything but then over time that ends
up building a very large cost structure
that gets passed along to the public so
you'd bring the costs down now you said
before Bernie's like free college for
everyone the problem with that solution
is it pretends that college solves the
employment problems of young people and
anyone who's coming out of college knows
that that's not real the underemployment
rate for recent college graduates today
is 44 percent so you have like a 50/50
shot if you come out of college you're
doing a job it doesn't really require a
degree and 94% of new jobs created right
now our gig temporary or contractor jobs
that don't have real path
forward or healthcare benefits of the
rest of it yeah I was reading something
about people actually it might have been
in that uh just telling you about you've
all know re yeah 21st century yeah it
was I always say that guy's name wrong
it's a tricky day you've all know a
herati yeah 21 lessons for 21st century
I think he was talking about how many
people plan on not being in the same job
in ten years because that job won't
exist anymore versus what it used to be
used to be the people would think that
they were going to get a job and they
would stick with job you know and now
they're planning that they're going to
have to move that they're not going to
be able to keep the same job and has
automation kicks in this is obviously
gonna bottleneck it's gonna get even
it's gonna give him worse yeah yeah
completely so the ideal is that you end
up training young people to be really
really adaptable and and have low cost
structures and just be able to you know
become entrepreneurs and I spent seven
years trying to train young people to do
just that but one of the things I've
discovered is that we're over
emphasizing college and what we're under
emphasizing is technical vocational and
apprenticeship work because a lot of
that work believe it or not it's
actually really hard to automate like
you know we're not gonna automate an air
conditioning repair person I'm a mom or
anytime soon and for sure craftsmen
people who build things and and it's
good for your mental health you know and
a bunch of other things so right now
only six percent of American high school
students are in technical or vocational
training in Germany that's fifty nine
percent give you a sense of what the gap
can mean so what we're doing is we're
over prescribing college we're saying
college college college for everyone
it's not really working that well and
then we're still treating people who are
working in trades and everything is
somehow you know like not in great
careers when a lot of those careers are
actually really awesome and they pay
great and they people enjoy them they're
persistent so right now we're gonna
automate away it's a lot easier to
automate all away a lot of repetitive
cognitive work than it is a non
repetitive manual work mmm because like
actual robot digits you know it's like
because if you can imagine what it would
take to ever robot plumber like come in
your house
that stuff's really really tricky yeah
there's a lot of fine motor work they
have to like unscrew pipes and like
stuff that stuff's not gonna get
automated for a long time you know what
is gonna get automated a lot of like
entry-level cognitive tasks a lot of
journalism tasks a lot of bookkeeping a
lot of stuff that college graduates
think they're gonna get a job in and
then those jobs are gonna disappear I
was a corporate attorney for those five
unhappy months and my friends are
working on AI that can automate away a
lot of basic legal work you know so
these college these college grads like
oh snap don't know what to do me I'll go
to law school didn't like load up with
another 120k and debt and then like the
the legal jobs are not going to be there
for him it's often the problem of their
parents giving them pressure to go into
college as well because they didn't want
the kid to become a loser and if the kid
you know like where I grew up in Boston
if you went into the trades if you
abandoned like the idea of higher
learning and going to college and just
went right into like learning to be a
carpenter or something that people look
at you like oh you sold yourself short
but there's so many people that I know
that went to school that just got
university degrees and then they got out
and they were [ __ ] yeah I mean it's
it's so common it's so common that they
thought there was going to be this path
and this path just didn't exist once
they got out or it was far far more
difficult than was then they were led to
believe yeah if you look at it about 32
percent of Americans graduated from
college right now and that level has
been more or less constant for a long
time
it's not like hey I've got another 20
percent I could get into college like
right now the college completion rate in
six years is about 59 percent so like
four out of ten people who start college
or not graduating in six years and a lot
of them are just not going to finish
ever so like they're the people that
have other paths available and we have
to build those paths up and this is one
reason why I'm so into the freedom
dividend instead of something like free
college because why would you subsidize
something that only the top third of the
population is gonna use you know and end
it's a highly inefficient costly system
anyway like money into that you're much
better off putting a thousand bucks a
month into every 18 year olds hands then
if they go to college great colleges
partially paid for they go to trade
school great trade schools partially
paid for they start their own business
they do something career
like they want to do something to help
that's great too like you can actually
start building more varied paths and
make it so that people don't feel like I
need to get into this institution or
else my life is going to be over now
what are the primary concerns that
people have outside of what you're
talking about so far with automation
taking away jobs and and you know
student loan debt and these things what
are the other things you think you're
gonna have to talk about in order to get
people to take you really seriously you
know I mean the hot-button issues you
know what they all are it's like
immigration and climate change is a
really big one and you know I mean I can
talk about those at length so my father
and mother met as immigrants from Taiwan
at UC Berkeley my father is a PhD in
physics he generated 69 US patents for
GE and IBM over his career so I'd like
immigrants are awesome immigrants come
in and you know it's like big stuff
happened for big American companies so
I'm very Pro immigrant and I think
people would expect that just to look at
me and so what I say is first it makes
no sense to educate international
students and US universities and then
send them home to compete against us
that makes no sense like if they're
gonna come to the u.s. and study we
should just staple a green card to their
diploma and be like hey you got a
diploma great news you can stay here and
work mmm as I personally know tons of
awesome internationals who would
definitely help make the u.s. more
dynamic and competitive that go home and
start the companies there and you're
like oh no like how that happens right
that's great for people who come from a
privileged background
yeah the opportunity to come here and
become educated but what about people
who are poor or trying to make it here
from South America yah Tamala
so school there are three paths
available to you for the approximately
12 million people who are here
undocumented many of whom from Mexico
and Latin America would not like that
you know frankly like they're not the
profile I just described for the most
part so there are three approaches
number one is you can pretend to deport
them because it's completely unfeasible
to deport 12 million people I mean like
whole regional economies would collapse
like you can't do matically like it
doesn't make any sense right number two
is you do nothing which is our current
path and then you have massive problems
- because there
constantly interacting with your schools
and your hospitals and getting into car
accidents and like you know it's like
just not knowing who the heck is who is
an untenable situation for any advanced
society so number three is you create a
pathway to citizenship and then you
integrate them into society but it's
like a long-term path that takes a
number of years and you need to keep
your nose clean and pay taxes and work
hard and do that seems to me the most
feasible yeah and so that's where we
should go and some Republicans were on
board with that until they like you know
paid a political price and then they ran
the other direction so that is really
the right path for people who are here
undocumented but I say to people a lot
that the opposite of Donald Trump is an
Asian guy who likes math so Donald
Trump's like build a wall and I'm like
look like I mean I'm we ought to enforce
a strong border like especially in a
world where everyone every citizens
getting a thousand bucks a month
like you got enforce it strong border
right at the same time you know like
people who are here they're making our
communities a lot more entrepreneurial
dynamic many of them mean at the high
end half of the Silicon Valley
entrepreneurs or other immigrants or
children of immigrants and that's true
in a different way in terms of like the
dynamism of these immigrant communities
so what I say to people is like if I'm
president people will see that you come
to this country and you work hard your
son or daughter can become president
United States now what do you do though
in this scenario that you just
subscribed if someone comes here and
they don't work hard and they don't keep
their nose clean and they are still here
and they're not a citizen yet yeah so
you know so then then they operate in
the informal economy in the way that
they have and that the truth is that
even if we have this pathway there gonna
be a significant proportion of people
who just do not trust us enough say hey
I'm here and I'm gonna like get in the
pipeline there's gonna be a lot of there
gonna be a lot of people that don't
subscribe but that's where it is right
now we're not making the situation
actively worse you know we can at least
improve the situation for a really
significant proportion of them yeah for
a significant proportion of them and you
know the other situation would be
tax revenue how many people that are
here illegally you're not paying taxes I
would imagine it's a enormous number
yeah there'd be a real economic boost if
we can integrate them into the formal
economy because there's a lot of just
cash going back and forth right thing is
it a lot of people might decide hey you
know what I don't even want to be a
citizen because if I'm a citizen I have
to pay taxes or I could work as a
laborer or work as a you know on
construction sites or whatever whoever's
willing to hire them and work for free
yes work rather with free taxes yeah and
yeah and so I mean that would still be
going on like that there are limits to
you know like what sort of appeal you
can have in terms of having people right
blether can have a path to real
prosperity have a real path to
citizenship would be very nice and it'd
be enormous for them cuz lot of them
have kids yes no no are their life but
but here so another issue I think you'll
like that comes up on the campaign trail
is what to do about marijuana and I'm
for full legalization remove it from the
federal controlled substance list and I
would go a step further and pardon
everyone who's in jail for a low-level
nonviolent drug offense because it makes
no sense to me to have people behind
bars for things that are legal in parts
of the country so my plan as president
is on April 20th of 2021 I'm going to
mass pardon everyone who's in jail for a
non-violent drug-related offense I'm
gonna high-five them on the way out I'm
gonna be very popular man that day we're
gonna be a lot of traveling to high-five
all those folks I know I'm gonna have to
go to a lot of places and high-five but
I really want to high five them Jerry
Lee yeah I mean that would be the
funnest freakin occasion so you know
that's something that comes up that to
me Mina it's obvious that marijuana you
know is an important remedy for many
people who are like in in various
struggling with various like health
problems and everything else I have
friends who are in that situation and
that it's certainly much less dangerous
than for example some of like the
opiates that have been getting
prescribed for the same the same things
yeah what do you do about that that's a
question that I have because I was just
reading something about some new
approved drug that's more
powerful than fentanyl which seems to me
to be completely insane
like we already have fentanyl and you
just you you make a mistake on whether
you know one of the things that happens
with people that overdose is especially
old people that are in pain when they're
using fentanyl or using any opiate on a
regular basis they sometimes forget if
they took it and you know look it's a
[ __ ] opiate I mean those they're very
powerful and if you're high on that
stuff and you forget whether or not you
took it and you go and take it again
you're dead yes and that that's a giant
issue they're too damn powerful and the
idea that you need something that's more
powerful than that seems to be insane I
agree with you it's it's irresponsible
the entire opiate crisis was generated
in part by the fact that the feds let
Purdue Pharma just go crazy prescribing
hundreds of thousands of oxycontin
prescriptions and that company man that
company got fine six hundred thirty five
million which sounds like a lot until
you realize they made like 16 billion
yeah so and those drop in the bucket
yeah so those those people are now some
of the richest people in the country on
the backs of American communities and it
just keeps morphing because I went from
oxy to heroin to fentanyl and then you
have people who are struggling with with
this addiction so to me to me it was
federal negligence that unleash this
plague I mean you got to hold the
sackler 's and Purdue Pharma accountable
because literally now they're profiting
from one of the treatment drugs it's
really obscene what they doing they're
just like hey my non-addictive wonder
drug turns out it caused a super plague
of lethal addiction for yeah hundreds of
thousands of Americans but now I'm gonna
sell you a new drug and you know try and
make money on the back end too so you
gotta get as much money as we possibly
can from that family in particular but
then you have to make resources
available and try and get people to
depend on these drugs less like I'm a
front end from the doctor end this is
like look why are you prescribing like
these opiates when like there's a doctor
I quoted in my book where he's like you
have never seen a lethality rate for
something prescribed for like a non
life-threatening condition yeah it's
like literally like non-trivial
percentage of people you prescribe an
opiate to will be dead in five years
yeah and the thing they came to you
you know for in the hospital wasn't like
crazy so so we have to make treatment
resource available but this is a very
human problem it's not a money problem
like you know you can throw money at
some problems and it works this thing we
should throw money at to try and give
people a fighting chance but then you
have to support the people coming out
because it's a brutal brutal process
trying to become whole and healthy if
you're an addict it is an unbelievably
brutal process and it's I have family
members that are affected by it and
people with hurt backs that got on these
pills and next thing you know they can't
get off of them and it's just it's
devastating and it's so common it's it's
just all everywhere country and they'll
be well prescribed and II for nothing I
had my nose fixed I had a deviated
septum and the doctor prescribed me two
different kinds of opiates and I said
I'm not in any pain and he said yeah but
you could be so here and I'm like but I
don't think this is a good idea I'm like
I don't even want anything he goes we'll
just take these just in case I want to
tell you I'm not playing tough guy just
didn't hurt yeah there's a little
annoying it was like my nose feels weird
but it would I didn't need [ __ ]
opiates
seriously man they're just willing like
here you go come on what are you pain
here you go come on a little this take a
little of that yeah and I have a
guarantee for you that their incentives
drive them more towards dispensing those
dragons and they're not yes those drugs
yes and it's in large part because the
incentive structure of our healthcare
system is so revenue oriented yes it's
like if I do more stuff if I give you
more stuff I make more money yeah if I
decide you don't need it I make less
money and that is one of the things
that's driving us all into this this
unhealth is that if you went to a doctor
who the Gimli was like you know I don't
think you need this stuff like that that
would be the way many of them would see
the problem if their paycheck was
unrelated to the amount of activity that
they were doing yeah when you look at
all the issues that plague this country
and you think about the possibility of
you were actually winning and becoming
president and then you look at what
happens to presidents when they win and
the amount of just aging to them do you
worry about that well first of all
Asians age very well
yes got that going for you that you know
and I'm married and you know we've got
two kids so I don't think she's going
anywhere they could be like kind of
tough for her to start over at this
point you know I mean one of my my
nightmare scenarios is I win
and then like I can't get stuff done the
way that because that's the forces
you've talked about this to where good
people go in a government they get stuck
like flies and amber because the system
is just designed to keep you from
getting anything done but one thing I
will say is that if you imagine a
scenario where the Asian man who wants
to give everyone a thousand bucks a
month becomes president United States in
2021 everyone's gonna know what how I
want it'll be like all right guys it's
dividend time and then Democrats will be
like yeah I like money for families
that's great and here's the the great
thing Joe is that then Republicans will
look at and be like wait a minute this
is a net transfer for rural areas for
red states on the interior am I really
gonna stand in the way of my
constituents right getting this dividend
and you can imagine me being like hey
what state wants to pass this first week
in every state yeah it would be into it
we can actually get this done this is a
bipartisan thing it's it's not left or
right it's forward and keep in mind the
state that has been demonstrated to love
this dividend is Alaska which is a deep
red conservative state here's a
Republican governor that passed the plan
in the first place he said who would you
rather get the oil money the government
who's just gonna screw it up or you the
people of Alaska and then people will
ask what like us please
wasn't that to incentivize people to
support their idea of drilling in some
controversial areas though there there
was probably you know a whole basket of
motivations but now that thing's been in
effect for 37 years is wildly popular so
I'm what I'm suggesting when you say
like hey you become president you can't
get anything done it's like I can get
one big thing done because I think it's
gonna be really popular among not just
progressives but also independents
libertarians like Milton Friedman is the
patron saint of libertarian economists
loved this plan because what
libertarians and conservatives hate is
government making people's decisions
what they like is economic freedom and
autonomy I just spoke at a libertarian
conference like Liberty Khan and was
like guys like the freedom dividend
would help people enjoy actual
freedom because you get a thousand bucks
a month like you know that makes you
more free to do all sorts of things like
you can like you know so you can like
make better choices and as long as the
government is completely like you know
it's like what you do is your business
so this can actually become something we
can get done the freedom dividend is a
great name to is like the Patriot Act
excited
freedom we're all about freedom who can
be no pain vote against that yeah who
could be against the freedom dividend
come on what kind of you know [ __ ] do
you have to beat this has gotta be
taking up a tremendous amount of your
time like woody if are you doing
anything else in addition to doing this
are you setting aside everything else in
your life other than your family
obligations I have two jobs man one help
accelerate society to try and deal with
this historic transition we're in and to
stay married those only things I'm about
wow that's a it's a powerful path now
when when you're looking at the
opposition and you look into all the
other people that are running for
president and wonder whether or not
they're gonna be there by the time the
elections were all around what it what
are you saying that's it's really
interesting Joe holy cow
that one of the funnest things about
running for president is you run into
all the other candidates on the trail in
Iowa in New Hampshire so I'm like just
hanging out backstage with like the gang
Brian it's so interesting and fun it is
weird sometimes but I've really liked
most of them and so sometimes people ask
me like hey who do you want your running
mate to be and I'm just like it really
depends upon who I just click with best
because we're just gonna be on the trail
all the time together so having met a
bunch of them I gotta say most of the
candidates are really genuine patriots
you just want to try and do something
positive and they see the country's
heading in the wrong direction I could
work with most all of them terms of who
I think is gonna be there in the end man
it's really interesting I mean one
reason I like I will say that apparently
the mainstream press had it out for
Bernie last time where they were just
gonna like I have a friend who worked in
the media and they were like just you
know kneecap Bernie no it's like like
there's definitely something going on
we're like certain corporate
media companies have certain candidates
they kind of want to tip the scales for
a little ride people don't want to like
tip it against well they thought that
Bernie was gonna get in the way of
Hillary winning is that the idea yeah
yeah I mean they were in the Hillary
camp for sure yeah and so that wasn't
just the media that was also the DNC
which is now on the record so now
happily certainly the DNC has turned a
totally different leaf where the DNC is
like we're not gonna do anything that
like here's with Eddie woods prospects
well what they did was a disaster
yeah in terms of public image - yeah
yeah I was both substantively and like
perception-wise disaster for them so
this time I got to say and and that that
team has turned over almost entirely
like it's almost totally different
people right and then the media I we
have the sense that you know they're
they're still feeling out who they're
gonna try and put the thumb on the scale
for so we're gonna bernie is still
running though right
um it looks like he's running yeah you
want to know something that's really
stupid but it changed my opinion of him
he was being grilled by someone at the
airport with a camera and he was
pretending to talk on the phone but you
could tell he wasn't really on the phone
plate and I saw that I was like yo you
can't do that you can't do that you
could say I'm not giving impromptu
interviews thank you very much and keep
walking like if you want to interview me
do it through the correct channels but
he didn't do that he pretended to be on
the phone it's a weird thing cuz if
you're willing to do that like that's
just that's just deceptive especially if
you can actually see the deception which
you can see the video the [ __ ] phone
is not on
it's like he's it's like you could see
his text messages he's like and the guy
saying to him you're not on the phone
the phone is like and he keeps walking
it's like I know that's a stupid thing
to but it's like huh we all you know we
all suss out details about different
people and yeah is you know and like you
know it's like I think one reason I'm so
grateful for this opportunity is it's
like you know like you actually can get
a sense of different people in different
environments and it does end up
impacting your your perception so I mean
people made decisions on much lesser
data points than that
that's it that way remember what the
[ __ ] his name from Vermont who Howard
Dean the Dean scream man the free
captures I what he's from he was from
Vermont was Vermont yeah that scream
killed him sank him do you remember the
Chappelle's Show parody the supposed to
a parody of that but the fact that it
was just because it was allowed like a
as a person who works in front of
audiences a lot when you're yelling into
a microphone like the the you hear like
especially if you don't have monitors in
front of you what you hear is like
everything you hear the crowd screaming
you hear everything and if you're
yelling into that microphone you're not
realizing what it sounds like as a
recording but with him is like yeah and
that was it one scream imagine imagine
that one scream literally changed the
course of that man's life one impulsive
you might have changed the course of the
nation's history my crazy I don't know
if that would happen today I think
especially post Trump one thing that has
happened is we're willing to forgive so
much more you know in some ways and some
ways no man I mean I feel like you know
like some some people more forgiving
than are those four different things I
for sure yeah there's certainly yeah it
varies but it would be interesting to
imagine what uh what the Dean scream
would result in today hopefully I'm not
the person that tested out yeah scream
please don't scream so what's next now
you you you're trying to elevate your
profile you're trying to make people
aware of your platform and what you're
how you're running what what is next
it's good fun man I'm enjoying running
for president more that's funny I would
that's a great thing here yeah like it's
so one thing is that when you talk to
Americans and you know like rural Iowa
or Manchester New Hampshire it's like
they're really good people like you know
it's like the stuff that you might
imagine is like ah people know it's like
really good honest genuine people just
trying to make their lives better people
I really love hanging out with our Union
guys like hi and the trucker's was fun
hanging out I hung all these Union metal
workers the other day in New Hampshire I
was like hey any like you know
BOTS going on fly here in your field so
that one of them was like yeah actually
like we used to take five to eight guys
to bend this rebar dive reinforce a
bridge now they bring in a robot it does
it overnight and then they're like
they're like hey good for you guys you
don't have to do this and then we're
like we just lost a freaking day so then
when I go in I talk to them about what's
going on in the economy they're like oh
man yeah like yeah that's like a real
problem and unions have been losing for
years like they don't know it like you
know memberships gone in half so just on
the campaign trail making the case to
different people I was on The Daily Show
last week and that's gonna film pretty
soon the next big benchmark for the
campaign is the Democratic primary
debates in June where they're gonna
bring all the candidates up and this is
something the DNC happily seems like
they're being really really open about
mmm which they it's not like hey you
need to you know like like have
particular things so I'm very confident
that we'll be on that debate stage and
then we can just keep on making the case
the American people when you're gonna do
something like done how do you prepare
do you do have someone throw fake
questions at you and you practice them
and practice the answers do you work
with a coach like how does that how
you're gonna do that for that given the
enormity of the occasion I'm sure we
will have something like that but I want
to double back in a conversation you had
recently with the guy named Lawrence
Lessig about campaign finance reform and
like they're all these interrelated
problems in our society and in my
opinion the automation wave is like
driving a lot of them because it's
making people less functional making
people less able to focus on the big
problems in the future and then part of
it is that our political systems held
captive by rich corporations and billion
like mega wealthy individuals and like
the average voter feels like my vote
doesn't matter
and so you know I was talking to
Lawrence Lessig is like hey how do we
fix it and I heard your conversation
with him and so a solution would be we
give every American adult $100 democracy
dollars that can only be contributed to
a political campaign and then you end up
counterbalancing and washing out a lot
of the corporate money because all of a
sudden if I get 10,000 people on board
with me that's like a freakin million
bucks no that's
very interesting that's an interesting
idea I like that a lot because that the
problem Joe is that a lot of our
regulatory approaches right now are like
the negative approach it's like don't do
this don't do that and the fact is a lot
of the time it's really hard to like
actually like regulate away a lot of
this stuff and so Lawrence was like you
know what let's just put money into
people's hands I can only go into the
political system and then it makes it so
if someone like me appeals to humans
then I get money as opposed to making it
so that the people and the money are
like two different sides of the equation
and I gotta say we were talking as a
team about being here and like you have
like the biggest audience of just about
any media platform in the country right
now like bigger than cable news bigger
than anything how [ __ ] did that happen
you know I mean Ted to me you're like a
you're the primary voice of reason right
now in our society man that's ridiculous
no I mean someone step up and take that
please I think it's you for the time
being brother
Brooks well what I was saying was that
like if if people that listen to this
conversation donate 10 20 bucks to my
campaign they're like 10 million people
are gonna listen to this that's like a
hundred to two hundred million dollars
and that's enough for me to go in and
break the the moneyed system I can go in
there and just say all right let's get
money out of politics and the way we're
gonna do it is we're gonna actually just
give people money to be able to restore
democracy in a real way do you have a
patreon page or anything like that my
website's yang 2020 calm and so our
average donation is only $19 so we joke
that my fans are even cheaper than
Bernie's is it the thing with people is
you got to make it easy make it easy
like have an Amazon one-click button
oh we were taking been mode for a while
yeah you know we were like working on it
it was a bit of a pain in the neck
administrative Lee hmm
I also want to say one other thing I did
I think will entertain the heck out of
you I'm giving a thousand bucks a month
to a family in New Hampshire and a
family of Iowa does that in my own
pocket just to illustrate you know what
a thousand dollars a month all actually
like do you and your household good and
these people we had a bunch of
submissions online for New Hampshire and
Iowa we're still taking submissions so
if you know people in Iowa they could
use a thousand bucks a month just go to
young 2020
come nominate them and then we'll pick
someone and there's no obligation so
it's out of my own pocket and there's no
obligation so the FEC was like well you
know no problem it's just a like act of
philanthropy or like you know a gift
right and then a family in South in
Georgia was so touched by my campaign
that there now is applying a thousand
bucks a month to a family in South
Carolina in honor of Martin Luther King
who was for basic income so we're really
inverting this mindset of like scarcity
and take take take and being like look
there's like plenty to go around with
like the richest and most advanced
society in the history of the world and
we can make lives better just by coming
together as a people there is nothing
stopping the majority of citizens in a
democracy from voting ourselves a
dividend I love the idea man I really do
and I love the idea of trying to find
solutions to this obvious issue that's
impending and that just seems like we're
not gonna escape I mean it seems like
automation is coming there's no way to
get around it no way there's no way
around it for sure I mean it's here with
us already it's inevitable and the
danger we're in right now is that if we
don't respond to it then there's going
to be a lot of a lot of anger about the
changes that are coming our way and so a
bunch of techies are actually supporting
my campaign because a lot of techies are
not jerks they're just like I'm doing my
job I'm just like you know my job
actually just tends to result in other
people losing their jobs right and so
what I say to them and they agree it's
like this is enlightened self-interest
for us all it's like progress should be
something we're excited about there is a
world where we're celebrating the fact
that the trucker's are getting liberated
from their trucks Brian because that's a
really difficult punishing job
especially in their backs yes
and so that the goal is to try and make
it so that people are actually able to
be happy about the inevitable mm-hmm you
know it's as I quote in my book Bismarck
was like if we're gonna go through a
revolution
you'd rather undertake it than undergo
it you know it's like like if the
revolution is coming then we need to get
in front of it and start making it work
for us
instead of just waiting for it to tear
us apart well I love the idea and it
would be amazing if you want I mean it
really would be fascinating and I said
I've done a complete 180 on the idea of
universal basic income particularly once
I start talking to you on about it when
and he was saying that it's inevitable
that you're gonna need something like
that that it's coming yeah and it closed
on this man it's like okay so if you
accept what Ilan said that it's
inevitable which I hundred percent agree
with let's say you go to early what is
the downside well let's see you
alleviate untold pointless human misery
and you have more time to build the
institutions and help us adapt yeah
that's the downside of you go too early
what's the downside of you go too late
the downside if you go too late is
literal disintegration and catastrophe
because it's not like society will
magically reorder itself if you're like
okay guys we're a little bit late to
this but like now we're gonna start you
know like putting checks into people's
hands yeah like so the incentives to go
early are pretty much all the incentives
it's like going too late is literally
society ending so if you accept what
Elon says which I agree with that look
this is inevitable then there's no point
in trying to like time it particularly
if you accept the fact that all of the
signs you would expect if we were
displacing labor are already there men
leaving the workforce like drug
overdoses video games like I like it's
all right there in front of us if you
just like take the rock and like flip it
over yeah and and the thing I'm gonna
say I you know a friend of mine Andy
Stern said is that our government is
terrible at most things but it is
excellent at sending large numbers of
checks to large numbers of people
properly and reliably yeah we have to
lean into one of the only core
competencies our government has that we
can trust and then it will let us make
our own decisions like this is very much
about human empowerment and the
alternative is too terrible to
contemplate last question because I
guess no discussion of presidential
policy and the possibility of someone
like you running this country's how how
do you feel about
International Relations and you know the
the obvious issues of dealing with other
countries and what's going on with China
and Russia and the interference of our
democracy and all the different various
issues that we've experienced over the
last particularly over the last couple
of years with Russia yeah sure
so about Russian you and I were talking
about this before we went on air when
I'm president I will say look Russia I
get it we have tampered with other
people's elections for years and decades
like we America I've done that you've
done it to us for the last number of
years it is going to stop right now
and if we have any credible evidence
that you are tampering with our
information in our democracy we will
take that as an act of hostility and
aggression and we will retaliate in some
way that will make your life very very
painful and inconvenient and you know
and the people of United States will
support me on this and so here is your
drop-dead date like turn off the bots
and if we find that your bots are still
going after this date I will just bring
the evidence the American people and
then we will act and you will not like
it one bit now if if I mean I'm thinking
80 90 percent of Americans would get
behind that it'd be like how are we just
like looking at it being like what are
we gonna do what are we gonna do and
then this one I actually feel a little
bit for the tech companies because it's
very difficult for the tech companies to
to prevent this almost impossible almost
impossible to identify and if you go
back to Sam Harris's podcast that we
were discussing which is called the war
of information I think that's what's
called information war or war of
information a recent podcast from the
last couple of weeks they detail how
there's essentially just giant groups of
people that work for the Russian
government that pretend to be people
that are involved in black lives matter
or pretend to be people that are
involved in Texas culture southern
culture and they're just sowing seeds of
argument and dissent and they are
laughing their asses laughing and making
funny memes like some of their memes are
really hilarious but but to them this is
the greatest ROI they've ever seen they
didn't really like return on investment
okay he's such an entrepreneur
YouTuber man I don't have a man hanger I
have a normal freaking house so like
they invested not even that much money
mm-hmm like but they found like this
underbelly that you can slice into
mm-hmm and so they've spent best
estimates like low tens of millions of
dollars and it's caused us how much
damage how much harm a real impact you
know like you know I mean you couldn't
even put a dollar figure on it so you
have to just say like look I get the
tech companies are gonna try but they're
not gonna be able to pull it off so just
like go on and just say like the world
and say hey this is to Russia but anyone
else
same thing like if you tamper with our
democracy we're gonna come down on you
like a ton of bricks and if we're not
quite sure we're still gonna come down
on you like a ton of bricks like I don't
need like a hundred percent certainty on
this I need like you know like a legal
standard I need like eighty eighty-five
percent and the American people would be
like about time because you know that if
we can't trust ourselves or each other
or what we're seeing and this is before
deep fakes and the rest of it starts
hitting like yeah like if you're
actually gonna believe in democracy then
you have to start protecting our
information as fast as possible and you
also in my mind have to start and this
is a local issue but I'm in New
Hampshire in Iowa talking about this
stuff they're local newspapers are all
dying
it's like thousands of local papers it's
winking out of existence because they
used to rely on classified ads there are
no classified ads anymore it's all
Craigslist and so they all die and if
you believe in democracy how the heck
can anyone vote on anything if they have
no idea what's going on so so there are
a lot of interrelated issues and one
thing I'm saying is like look we had a
happy time where local newspapers were
supported by classified ads it's over
now but we're still a democracy you
still need some information to vote so
we need to try and find new ways for you
to get quality information like that
those throwing our hands up and being
like yes the Russians are gonna you know
like in like just miss inform us with
BOTS and I guess all the local
newspapers are gonna die like you said
like these are problems and we have to
start solving them if you still believe
that democracy is the best form of
government and that's what we're going
to carry forward with would you
obviously have to believe like you have
to go with that as your model and so
it's all interrelated
but we have to start thinking much much
bigger about what we can get done
because things are slipping away things
are trending in a terrible terrible
direction
well Andrew good luck to you you're a
good man
I wish you well thank you for being here
I think your message is excellent and I
hope you really make an impact Thank You
Jose really appreciate it man president
yang man if I if I win if I win you can
do a special JRE from the White House
and that would be a blast let's do it
thank you sir
appreciate it man
[Music]
[Applause]